Hi everyone, in this lesson we're going to go and take a look at the FX Outliner in regards
to Niagara optimization.
So let's get started.
Now the FX Outliner is in that debug tool section and is one of the tools that we can
use to maybe take a look at our scene and kind of see how performance is going.
Now do you have to use it?
No, you can probably get away with not necessarily using it in your scene.
There are some refresh issues that may occur, especially if you want to catch information
and look at the simulation and see how it's going.
You also will see there's a capture button, but you can also hit that capture button in
the details of the effect itself to instantly capture some of that data.
Now it just does a snippet and kind of gives you an overall estimate of what's going on.
You will see that you can also control the lane of the view, of the playback if you wanted
to.
You can see the light of it in your view mode.
You can have it descending and us sending order if you need to as well as look at your
units in milliseconds and seconds if you wanted to or seconds.
It's up to you.
And then from there you can go into each one of your effects and it grabs all of them all
at one time and you can kind of analyze and see what's going on under the hood.
Let's go ahead and jump into Unreal and we'll take a peek at this.
Let's go ahead and click on capture.
That's the tool you will use to capture that session and what's going on.
You see it kind of cleared out what we had before.
And if you do run into any refresh issues, feel free to close the debugger, reopen it
and then run that catch information again or capture, I should say, and then you'll get
the information you need.
Again we can control delay.
You'll see here we have a view mode where we want to see the state performance or debug
overall.
And again we also have filters where we can go in here and look at our system execution
state and our emitter execution state.
So if you needed to deactivate these if you wanted to or see what's inactive you can and
compute them.
Now again, this is just a quick analyzing tool.
It isn't necessarily perfect.
You'll see there's a playback, a pause, a loop and a step back and speed and refresh.
So if we open this up, we'll actually see our effect in here and we'll show our different
effects for this class.
You'll see that there's a capture as well as an opening of what is active and what isn't
active.
Now we have this here in our scene and we can choose, you know what, I'm going to go ahead
and take a look at my scene overall.
I can run a capture here.
Now I may pause the video here because this does a little bit of a hog when it comes to
your simulation.
And just keep that in mind if you are going to capture this information.
It may be a little bit slow and it may need a little bit of a refresh.
So I made sure all my arrows are open here so you can see what's going on.
So let's go ahead and run a capture and we'll run a sim.
There we go.
Now it may take a while for the interface to pop up, but the interface is going to bring
in another layer of information.
Basically going to break things down for us.
We'll run a capture again.
We'll do the sim here.
And let's see what we get.
Now if it doesn't come up the first time, just hit that sim button one more time and
you should get this here, a pop up, which allows us to be able to actually look at another
win menu, be able to look at all the information for the effect and all the different aspects
of that effect that we have in here.
And we'll let me know what's going on.
So it just gives you kind of a detailed list of where our effect is, where it's landing,
where you can scroll down and find different modules in here like, oh, hey, we got a control
here for a red, green, and blue.
Do we do anything with this?
This effect, the milliseconds, how much particles are being pushed through this?
Is there any extra erroneous stuff I don't need?
So it really just gives you an overall analyzing of your effect and your scene and those sim
and the catch just gets that information and kind of breaks it down for you.
If for some reason you need to look at that a bit deeper and you can see here all the
information that we have in here, letting us know what's going on.
Again, these tick boxes are going to give you those categories for each thing that you
want to analyze.
And Unreal is pretty great at being able to categorize things for you.
And again, it'll tell you if you just float over, if you got what tick box you turned
on, it'll tell you what in context, what this is on the part of that particle.
That is being looked at.
But be aware, when you hit that capture button, things will come to kind of a crawl.
So be careful.
Just be patient.
And then again, just give you a snapshot of what's going on in your scene.
And when you run these captures and the Sims, they're really just giving you a spreadsheet.
So again, nothing necessarily to write home about, but can give you the information you
need.
And then notice as I click on each one of these effects, I can actually see what's
going on and what I have in place for my settings, what I have active and also what
category is this particular effect.
You can also see is it GPU or is it CPU will also show up.
And then you also like I pointed out before can choose milliseconds, seconds in here if
you need to.
Now, again, the other ones, which I mentioned earlier also performance, session, browser,
and debug are all kind of in development still.
So they may not give you exactly what you're looking for.
Those are evolving, getting faster, stronger.
The most the time when I'm working with this, I'm going to be working with the FX Outliner.
If that, I will definitely be working with the debug hut.
Now, the debug mode can easily be switched if I need to.
And I can go from debug mode to state mode.
If I want to, as well as I can go to performance mode and performance gives me a bit of a
breakdown here.
Let's go and look at the slides at exactly what we're looking at information wise and
how this can possibly help us.
So you can see here we have number one, which is the average total frame time for all effects.
We have number two here, it shows the maximum total frame time for all effects.
We can also go down or I should say off to the left, go to number three and we'll see
the average per instant cost for this system.
We go to four, you'll see the maximum per instance cost for the system.
We'll see five here, which is the average total cost for all instances of the system.
And we go to six where it says maximum total cost of all instances for the system.
We'll go to seven here and you'll see the average cost for this instance.
And then again, we'll see here at eight.
Finally, that is the maximum cost for this instance.
Now I know that's a lot.
This is why I put it in the slide for you because even I can forget this.
There's a lot of numbers here, but you can now see and see the breakdown of how this
is read and how this can benefit you.
You can kind of see how this is overall going to affect your performance.
You can adjust things, look at things in milliseconds.
I need to tone this down.
This is too much.
So this mainly has to do with a lot of effects.
A lot of times the case in point when to use this is if you have a lot of effects in your
scene and you really need to micromanage them and you really need to somehow get them to
play a lot better with each other in the scene with all the other assets you have in play.
Now remember, there are ways around this and we'll talk about this in the next lecture.
You can also bake things to, we have a baking method where you can bake it like to a simple
piece of geometry.
The only problem you can run into there is the quality can degrade.
So VDBs are also an option, which I do have a class coming up on that which shows you
how to use VDBs and also get them in sequencer.
Those are effects, if you're unfamiliar with that, those are effects coming from Houdini
or Maya or Embergen.
You can bring them into Unreal and use them also.
And they are a bit lighter.
It just kind of depends how many you have in your scene, everything within context.
You can break anything if you put too much on it.
But for the most part, they can actually help out if you needed the effect to look pretty
realistic, but not necessarily have a high playback cost.
But again, anything you can put too much on anything and you can bring things to a crawl.
So everything has to be optimized in such a way where your hero objects and effects
are up front and the things that are not that important can be put in the background.
Now, we also have the option where if you baked things out into, say, you had Houdini
and you baked it out into an EXR, you can actually import those in.
And I give you a link at the end of this class.
You can put those on a car geometry and you determine whether or how that alpha is going
to be read, but you can actually put that in the background if you need to.
And that actually is another option to keep things down.
And those can be options definitely explored when it comes to ICV effects or virtual production.
That's it with this video.
In the next video, we'll talk about that very same thing about baking your effects and
using the tool in Unreal.
Thanks again.